Speaker 1: Today, we're going to be speaking
with Reece Peck, who's an associate professor
at the City University of New York and also
author of the book Fox Populism Branding Conservatism
as Working Class.
Really appreciate your time and for being
here today.
Speaker 5: Yeah, my pleasure.
Speaker 1: So to start with, either my my
understanding of the history of political
media, including sort of as described by the
book Waves of Rancor, which starts with the
use of low power F.M. and talk radio and sort
of all the way through where we are now is
that the political right and the political
left have used media differently.
Part of that has to do with ownership structure
and issues related to money and financing.
But part of it also has to do with the right,
quite frankly, having better, I would argue,
more effective sort of bumper sticker phrases
that better lend themselves to some forms
of media.
Can you talk a little bit about the current
landscape and how you would sort of distinguish
the way the political right and left use media?
Speaker 5: Yeah, well, first off, the right,
it's hard to talk about the kind of right
versus left media.
You really have to think about a kind of liberal
corporatist center that dominates the mainstream
legacy media and then this massive right wing
sector that's always been there for multiple
generations, and then this little sliver of
truly leftist media and alternative spaces.
So you kind of have to break it down in a
tripartite model.
It's harder to talk about like left media
versus liberal centrist media, but the left
media, in terms of the history of alternative
left media, I mean, today there's a common
sense notion that the mainstream media is
liberal, has a liberal bias.
But if you took a time machine to the 1930s
when they talked about the bias of the press,
it was always the capitalist press or the
conservative press.
And so labor unions and lefties had to create
these alternative revenue models, had to kind
of fight their way to get on radio.
And it's always been this uphill, uphill battle.
I mean, if you're critical of capitalism and
the media system you exist in, it's commercial
in nature, right?
It's an uphill battle for funding for legitimacy.
And so that's largely the history of the left,
like the true left kind of alternative media,
the conservative media.
Inversely, I guess you'd say when you have
this pro-business, class, free market ideology,
the ways that you're back, right?
You're basically telling media executives
and billionaire donors that they're the moral
history.
I mean, they're the moral heroes, they're
the job creators.
So they're going to look kindly on you and
your in your content.
And so but I don't think that structural analysis,
it can only go so far.
And I think leftists throw their hands in
the air and they say, well, we don't have
the same billionaire backing, we don't have
the same funding.
And I think you're very right to say there
are things in which left media creators do
to tie their own hands, to shoot themselves
in the foot, in terms of messaging, in terms
of style, in terms of narrative.
That that has really catapulted the right
is I completely agree with you.
They're kind of more sophisticated in terms
of their communication and media strategies.
Speaker 1: Can you talk a little, give some
examples of that?
And, you know, I mean, when I talk to others
in the left media space and when I talk about
that, just to be really clear, I'm not talking
about MSNBC.
MSNBC is sort of like a Democratic Party center,
left positioning corporate profit motives
that are identical to Fox News, etc., even
if some of their policies are different, certainly
their editorial perspective is different.
But when I talk to other people in like left
independent media, there are many who say
I would gladly accept the millionaire or even
billionaire donors of The Daily Wire if they
came to me and said, Hey, I want to give you
money to do exactly what you're doing.
The counterpoint to that is those who say,
No, no, no, no, no.
By the very nature of having those millionaires
or billionaires supporting you, you would
not be able to do what you're doing.
That's the difference between what the left
wants to espouse and what the right wants
to espouse.
So how much of it is that the messaging of
the left is not appealing to those moneyed
interests versus something else?
Speaker 5: Well, I would say that there was
no shortage of millionaire billionaire money
for right wing media in the 1950s and sixties
seventies, but they were not nearly as successful.
And so it was all money and donations.
And how come William Buckley wasn't, you know,
a kind of populist tabloid hit, or how come
the first generation of conservatives were
so ineffective, their media before Limbaugh,
before Fox News, was largely on the margins.
It was a boutique kind of segment of the conservative
movement.
It was only when you get to Limbaugh where
you see this blend of kind of profitability.
They were they're a profitable commercial
entertainment product and then conservative
ideology.
And it's when the conservatives really, with
Murdoch's influence, embrace his tabloid style
and populist style and integrated insights
from tabloid the public affairs genres like
talk radio or tabloid television, that the
right attain this kind of level of cultural
dominance and prevalence that it did.
And so I think there's lessons to be learned
from the left, right, the left has this inflexible
commitment to this kind of upper middle class,
educated, imagined audience in mind when they're
when they're designing their style or they're
designing their kind of consumer appeals and
they're averse to this tabloid esthetic, they're
averse to kind of populist modes of engagement.
And I think that's, you know, the success
of the right is largely a story of them shifting
toward a different style that's more conducive
to mass taste and kind of working class identity.
Speaker 1: So going back, like, what are the
stylistic mistakes that you think the left
is making that limit the appeal?
Speaker 5: Well, I think the left in especially
when, you know, there was this coming to Jesus
moment when George W Bush won his second term.
And that was when you see this explosion of
kind of anti Fox Media ventures.
We got to do something about Fox.
You get you know, Air America is launched.
You know, you get Jon Stewart kind of coming
into his own and critiquing and then you get
a, you know.
OLBERMANN a little later.
And so there's this moment where they're like,
we need an unapologetic kind of form of progressive
media to counter what Fox is doing.
I think my critique there is they went all
in on sarcasm and comedy in this kind of ironic
style.
That was the way they were going to be popular
or appealing.
And that has its uses.
And we all like to a degree to satirical style.
But I think it's limited when you have other
ways you can speak to people with sincerity,
with emotional expressiveness, with recruiting
certain personalities that don't come from
prestige sectors of the journalism field.
And that's exactly what Fox did.
MSNBC had a slight moment of flirtation with
populist styled hosts, with Jake Sugar and
Dylan Ratigan and Ed Schultz.
And those shows did good.
They were they had pretty good ratings.
But it was I would say it's because of their
middlebrow taste culture that it was off brand
with MSNBC.
They were trying to appeal to this educated,
affluent demographic and they didn't want
to, you know, alienate them with this populist
sensibility.
And so I think that that that's the key to
me.
And every time the last kind of plays with
this, they generally abandon those kind of
hosts, those kind of styles.
Speaker 1: George Lakoff has a perspective
where, media aside, he argues that some of
the arguments of the right are just structurally
better suited to commercial media.
Like a couple examples would be, Hey, abortion's
murder, so it should be banned.
And on the left, it's like, well, you know,
we've got to talk about viability.
And then you have to understand sort of like
the 40 week pregnancy and mammalian gestation.
And we have to it's not like a good bumper
sticker phrase or, hey, the taxes, it's my
money.
Let me keep my money.
Whereas the left is like, well, yes, one society's
get large enough, some roles need to be centralized.
And so we have to find the right tact, right?
It's like.
So he makes a more linguistic sort, that sort
of approach it.
How how important is that versus like strategic
media decisions that are made by left and
right?
Speaker 5: I think it's critical.
You know, I'm not, you know.
LAKOFF The insights of Lakoff is that the
first way we interface with politics is often
through these moral registers.
It's not through these, like, nuanced policy
discussions or what the facts are.
We really start with esthetics and moral frames
and then we move to the policy.
Though it's not that those things don't matter.
It's just the way in which people interface
and the sequencing that they kind of come
to engage in politics through.
And and I and I agree.
I mean, there's other civil rights leaders
like Reverend Barber, he's excellent.
He's he's been calling for the progressives
to develop what he calls a kind of universal
moral language.
And it doesn't mean when you speak in these
moral terms, you have to abandon nuance or
complexity.
It's just to recognize that that is engaging
from the from up front, Right.
That you're really laying out these kind of
positions in the right is really good at recognizing
not just speaking in a moralistic way, but
recognizing what moral political stories have
had resonance over time.
They're very good at looking at, like you
just mentioned, this idea that I work hard
and I deserve the fruits of my labor, right?
There's there's a way you could frame that
in a left wing way.
Yeah.
The labor movement works hard and they're
the ones who create wealth, right?
You could use that same moral frame like FDR
did, but the right captures that co-ops and
then turns that into a story about the fruits
of labor is really giving these business people
and the job creators like all their hard work.
And so we need to not attack them because
they're the most productive segments of society.
So the right is like very savvy at recognizing
which narratives have resonated and cycled
over political history and where the left
kind of shows these things and what the name
of intellectual complexity or that it's too
hokey or corny.
And I just think that again, that's another
way.
And yet they're shooting themselves in the
foot.
Speaker 1: What do you make strategically
about the recent focus from the Republican
Party in media on the culture war stuff?
Anti-woke the trans issues?
You know, men in women's sports, as they like
to call it, etc..
You know, a lot of the rhetoric is the same
rhetoric that was assigned to gay men ten
years ago that has just moved on now and taken
a little bit of a different tone.
But do you think that from a media studies
perspective, that it is a logical thing for
the right to be doing temporarily or even
on the medium term, or is it a mistake strategically?
Speaker 5: It all depends on if, you know,
Murdoch has always been very good at taking
something that seems, you know, somewhat petty
like Eminem's be having, you know, you know,
androgynous boots on or something like that.
And everyone that laughs, the left laughs
at it, right?
We're like, Oh, it's so ridiculous.
They care about these little things.
But it's the way in which they'll take something
that is palpable and mundane and everyday
and connect it to the broader world of politics.
And that actually makes politics more palpable,
gives it texture.
And so they're only successful if they just
get too in the weeds with CETA, with CRT and
trans issues, and don't connect it to these
broader narratives about how liberals look
down on us.
And they're part of the educated elite and
they're the campus based crowd and we're the
working class crowd.
That's when those kind of cultural war narratives
pack their biggest punch.
But it's like when I look at the Santas, for
example, he just lacks that ability to take
those issues and kind of turn them into broader
class narratives about elitism and about we're
on the side of authentic people and normal
people, and he's just overly on line.
And it just seems like it starts to seem like
you're actually just you're your tactic is
to make it.
You're just scapegoating.
You're creating a scapegoat for the sake of
creating a scapegoat.
And it doesn't feel like it has this broader
populist message where Trump is very good
at exploiting those class cultural tensions
between the college educated and the non-college
educated class.
So I think that's where they are.
The best is when they can package it in some
sort of larger populist class critique.
It's at its worst when it just as nakedly
bigoted and nakedly a kind of subculture of
the right that they're obsessed with an extreme
kind of religious subculture.
Speaker 1: Speaking of like the online media
space versus kind of like outside of it, one
of the conversations I had with my audience
during the 2020 Democratic primary was that
spending a lot of time on Twitter and Reddit
would likely give you an overemphasized perspective
on how popular Bernie Sanders is within the
Democratic Party.
And I had the belief, and I think there was
polling to bear it out, that people who are
just like working in Michigan and then picking
up their kids and going home, they're not
necessarily on Twitter and Reddit in the same
way if they're on it at all, and that Joe
Biden's support among the Democratic Party
voters is likely much higher than it seems.
And this seemed to be the case now.
Yes, to some degree, there was this coordinated.
Everybody got out of Joe Biden's way after
South Carolina.
That's that's true.
But I think the point kind of still remains
there.
Has this online discourse actually become
deceptive in terms of figuring out what, quote,
what people care about, maybe not only on
the left, but also on the right in the sense
that I don't know that that many Republican
voters, the sorts of people that kind of want
like a Chris Christie or a mitt Romney are
that engaged with like the so-called men and
women's sports thing or the anti-woke has
online really distorted what people care about.
Speaker 5: I mean, I think undeniably, you
know, I think that what when you really get
to the 2016 election, which is really this
important, pivotal shift, I think, in our
media culture and our politics, where, you
know, you're no longer, you know, seen Obama
dance with Ellen DeGeneres and Hillary Clinton,
you know, goes on stage with Beyonce.
It's like this is that old kind of monoculture
model, right?
The vestiges of the network era where you
could still do that kind of politics.
What we see in 2016 is the online fringes
start to emerge and have outsized influence,
kind of erasing this normie kind of middlebrow
political center.
Right.
And so it's it creates this perception that
they're bigger or they're more representative
of both their respective political sides than
they actually are.
And I think you're right.
I kind of was guilty of that, too, when you
when you consumed Bernie kind of aligned media
so much, you know, when the 2020 election
happened.
I realize that there are people that are actually
have much more cemented Democrat, pro-Democratic
party normie loyalties.
MSNBC and CNN actually did have some power.
Regardless of all the calls that they're dying,
they're dead.
They're irrelevant.
Yeah, you know, I think they show they're
still kind of shaping what your average middle
of the road Democratic voter thinks.
And so I'm with you.
I mean, I think there is there is an overconfidence
sometimes with the kind of alternative political
media spheres.
But with that said, it is undeniable that
people are cord cutting.
It's undeniable that cable is in decline and
that even the writing's on the wall.
Even those organizations have tried to do
an over-the-top streaming model, Fox Nation,
CNN.
Plus they're seeing how the independent alternative
sphere is getting larger and larger and larger
and wielding more political influence.
So I think we're in this moment of transition,
right?
So it's hard to prognosticate, like, what's
water?
Who's listening to who?
Who's driving the agenda?
It's much more unclear than it was back in
2008 or even at the beginning of 2016, that's
for sure.
Speaker 1: We've been speaking with the associate
professor at the City University of New York,
Reece Peck, also author of the book Fox Populism
Branding Conservatism as Working Class.
Reece, really appreciate your time and insights
today.
Speaker 5: Thank you.
Thank you for having me.